والان الى وضع الفتيات والتعلم في
افغانستان فبينما تستمر حركه طالبان في
حظر الفتيات الافغانيات من التعليم يرسل
بعض القدم من الحركه بناتهم الى الخارج
للدراسه واستكمال لتعليمهم وفقا لتقرير
نشرته تايمز البريطانيه والتي اشارت ايضا
الى وجود انقسامات غير مسبوقه بين قياده
طالبان بشان حظر تعليم الفتيات ما اثار
بعض الامل في التغيير هذه الامل مشاهدينا
تصطدم بافكار زعيم الحركه هبه الله اخوان
زاده الذي تصفه الصحيفه بالرجل الغامض حيث
يرى ان منح النساء حقوقهن سوف يقود سلطه
جماعتهم الصحيفه تقول ان هناك املا في
مقاومه ناعمه داخل الحركه نفسها لقرارات
زاده اذ يتم بالفعل تحدي حظر التعليم
بهدوء مثلا كالسماح بالمدارس المجتمعيه
غير النظاميه من قبل قاده محليين في
طالبان او بغض الطرف عن المدارس السريه